Тарифи на електрику для населення цього року підвищувати не будуть.
У цьому українців запевнив прем’єр-міністр Денис Шмигаль
під час онлайн-трансляції одного із засідань уряду.
У ЗМІ поширюється неправдива інформація про нібито збільшення тарифів на електроенергію.
Не варто вводити наших громадян в оману.
Ще раз підкреслюю, в цьому році ціна на електроенергію для українських громадян
буде незмінною – 1,68 грн за один кіловат.
Щоправда, на думку експертів, економічного підґрунтя
для таких оптимістичних обіцянок немає.
А штучно утримувати ціни на електрику на низькому рівні,
постійно дотуючи їх з бюджету, немає сенсу.
Чому українцям не уникнути підвищення цін на електроенергію -
якщо не цього року, то наступного?
Нині загальний тариф для населення в Україні становить 90 копійок за кіловат-годину
при споживанні до 100 кіловат, і одну гривню 68 копійок за кіловат-годину, якщо більше.
За даними Євростату, електрика для побутових споживачів в Україні є найдешевшою у Європі.
До того ж, удвічі дешевша навіть у порівнянні з двома іншими країнами
з найдешевшою електрикою для населення - Грузією та Молдовою.
У Німеччині, приміром, кіловат-година для побутових споживачів
коштує усемеро дорожче, ніж в Україні.
При цьому парадокс у тому, що, маючи найдешевший тариф для населення,
тариф на "зелену" енергетику в Україні - один з найдорожчих у Європі.
В Україні дуже вигідно виробляти струм з відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Держава викуповує цю електрику за значно вищими цінами.
Приміром, виробники сонячної енергії отримують понад 4 гривні за кіловат-годину,
виробники вітрової - понад 3.
Тоді як "тепловики" - гривню двадцять.
А "атомники" взагалі - 67 копійок за кіловат-годину. Тобто в рази менше.
"Зелені" тарифи запровадили в Україні понад 10 років тому
фактично під соратників експрезидента Януковича - братів Клюєвих,
які одними з перших побудували великі сонячні станції на півдні України.
Частка "зеленої" енергії все ще невелика - близько восьми відсотків.
Для порівняння - на атомну енергетику припадає понад 50 відсотків.
Однак з'ясувалося, що енергомережа не готова приймати навіть такі скромні обсяги
"зеленої" енергії і протягом останніх місяців диспетчери вимушені були час від часу
зменшувати виробництво на атомних чи інших електростанціях.
Ситуація ускладнюється ще й тим, що споживання електроенергії в Україні
нині скоротилося внаслідок кризи, спричиненої пандемією COVID-19.
Тож, через високі тарифи і збільшені обсяги виробництва "зеленої" енергії
у держави банально вже не вистачає коштів, аби викуповувати її,
як це передбачає українське законодавство.
Держпідприємство "Гарантований покупець", яке цим займається,
фактично банкрут і заборгувало "зеленим" виробникам мільярди гривень.
Експерти зазначають, що нинішня встановлена державою ціна атомної електроенергії
не покриває навіть палива, не говорячи про витрати "Енергоатому" на ремонтні роботи
та загалом підтримку АЕС у безпечному технічному стані.
Тож, підвищення тарифів на електроенергію для населення не уникнути.
За словами експертів, варто діяти, як з платіжками за газ
- поступово наближати ціни на електроенергію до ринкових,
а соціально незахищеним українцям надавати грошові субсидії.
Крім того, зазначають аналітики ринку, варто переглянути "зелений" тариф,
зменшивши його на третину, а квоти на нові потужності надавати лише тим виробникам,
які запропонують найнижчий тариф.
Усе це неможливо без демонополізації українського енергоринку,
на якому 80 відсотків теплової генерації контролюють компанії
мільярдера Ріната Ахметова.